the champion of all-stars three is
[Music]
Trixie Mattel now immediately after the
fan reaction was very mixed it was
either totally team Trixie Oh or the
angriest people alive well you know to
me was all positive until people like
you brought it up so it was weird cuz I
was like the morning after I won drag
race what a great day and then everybody
was like how are you dealing with the
negative kick back I was like I'm rich
Stephanie have a great day like it
doesn't apply to me it was odd because
everybody was team Trixie team shangela
and then when it wasn't shangela top two
they were team nobody but um I did that
damn thing so I've like zero regrets to
this day I'm like a shangela super fan
I'm the girl in the front yes queening
her so however I can't give her my crown
sceptre any money
beside shangela she'll just come up
tomorrow and drive by she'll pop out of
a box and fine but you know I'm any
season in season ten season nine people
are a little more apt to they celebrate
who wins until they win and then they
celebrate who should do should have won
you were robbed hundred been robbed it's
awful I've been robbed I've been robbed
like a robbery it's awful television
show that celebrates artists is not a
robbery that being said I think you're
going home tonight
speaking of all-stars we know another
season is coming we don't know who's
going to be on it no we have no idea but
the reddit detectives have put together
a list of people they think are going to
be on it yeah we have to remember we're
trusting investigative journalism from
teenagers in Iowa yes
so a grain of salt grain of salt but I
want to read each of these names and
just get your first reaction to them
being on the show pheromone oh I love
pheromone I'm all about celebrating drag
queens for what they're good at
and I could just watch her just I mean I
just find her funny and
so pretty and that's enough for me she's
when I think I looking drug she is a
woman one man the makeup the little body
the little voice to himself who else to
else are they hypothesizing gia Gunn
oh I loved you see I like the product a
pretty I like women yeah
give me the women I just want girls and
nice dresses being girls I basically
want like bachelor like bad girls club
girls I'm like a clown
people think that I'm only gonna like
clowns but I mean I like women a girl a
drag queen I love Gina and she's a very
underrated life performer her
lip-syncing
oh I mean like the full like this and
the Colleen ponytail to the whip cracks
oh my god helps you access but purse
again maybe bigger yeah
Jasmine masters Oh Mike is like my
dreams did I guess
Jasmine masters is um you know I hate
the word underrated because it's like
when people are saying like wow
everybody sleeps on her what they're
really saying is nobody likes her but
everybody loves Jasmine masters and
she's like the unsung super favorite of
drag race I mean Justin Bieber posted
videos of her rightful love her no tea
no shade no pink lemonade I'm not
reading but it is just the truth I
relate to her too because I think on
season seven she wasn't much of a
competitor and I'm not much of a I'm not
a competitive spirit person according to
Jazzmaster she just wants to smoke some
weed eat some food make some coin and
love on her friends
that's her for montrose she could make
some coin yeah she wins Latrice Royale
ah this is again my Dreamcast going
along but she's is amazing June she did
the splits like she never does it but
I've seen it
Manila Luzon I come on I mean I want I
hope this list Israel I meet you this is
a good cast it's real I'm like oh wow
you've got some throwback gals and some
newer gals I want like a Sharks and the
Jets have like the old Queens and the
young cream well and Latrice a Manila
both competed on all-stars one which was
a different show a different show and
they were not a winning combination
ultimately no Latrell I believe was
their name I think so
I'm a fan of the program mone exchange
oh I love my dad pretty Bob pretty Bob
I call her ah Jim McDonald on HGH you
know she and she wears the Pussycat wigs
uh which I like it
she's a great lip syncher and so funny
and on her season cracker and Monet were
my two picks and so um obviously I ended
up being disappointed but but hey if
she's on the second chances third
chances even at first you don't succeed
convinced ben de la creme Dilip I'm
going home
Monique art oh my god again this is like
my fully Dreamcast right now she is so
fabulous I'm being so nice though you're
just picking all these people actually
like who else did you have anybody I
hate well I got three names left let's
see Naomi smalls hater No
Oh Naomi smalls is amazing her legs are
legendary I feel like it's like Mean
Girls but they're like I heard her hair
is insured right if Naomi was smart she
would chop off her legs and just sell
them you want to walk around you wanna
be rich but Trinity Taylor oh my god
I've ever had that list she's the most
competitive oh she's not row serious
competitor I remember her lip sync - um
I want to go
[Music]
[Applause]
the hair flips the hair flips I don't
care whether you have long hair or not
you were like at a gay bar watching it
like you were trying to follow and
you're like you were getting dizzy oh
and I think she's got another dose job I
think she did right after that her
season aired thank God
and then Valentina Lou wildcard
I don't know I mean uh she's an odd
character huh she isn't our character
she was like three different people her
first season yes
you know what I'm an ambassador of drag
race and I celebrates the bull for what
they're good at
nobody has ever even competed with the
beauty of her face and I like people who
sort of operate the fantasy world I'd be
interested to see what two years of time
touring has done for Valentina is she
perhaps a how could she get more
beautiful yeah I'd have to think the
Valentina we saw on TV was poor
Valentina right let's just try to drag
Valentina looks like that's gonna be
different this is what Richard Simmons
hell looks like so obviously we all
operate in different levels
I like this trick oh yeah potato sack
this would be a good option for a drag
con outfit yeah the body's a mystery you
can wear a panty or not where it's not
yeah
just go about your day with a mystery
and a pee dress is a good Petros oh yeah
smart thing to think about
yeah oh here's a tip for drag con I
there is not private fantasy Talent
bathrooms so you might just go to the
bathroom and see like you know I don't
know ginger Minj one leg up on the
urinal or something so it could happen
now I mean that's a very different kind
of dish Neill an excuse more of a sit to
pee individual
[Applause]
[Music]